I was talking to your boss this morning
in the green room and uh there was
mention that you were going to be on and
he got a big smile on his face and he
said oh she's definitely going to throw
me under the bus oh of course I am
that's I wrote an entire book trying I
actually tried to throw him under the
bus and I just threw myself under the
bus yeah all the time but yeah no I mean
he's because I've worked for him for so
long that I'm I'm so used to how he is
and the things that he does and the
things that he says that I just at this
point it's any propriety between an
assistant and their boss is just gone
it's out the window so I have a couple
questions about your book because the
book is there's some fascinating claims
in this book you uh requested to take
your initial interview laying down or
did I mess that up no I made a joke okay
he was like oh it's it's just a you know
it was Conan and and two of our
producers and uh he was like just be
just be casual it's a it's a very casual
conversation and so I was like can I
just lay down on the couch and then I
think that joke is what got me my job as
soon as I said a joke he was like all
right she's hired it was that it was
that sort of that's all it was but it
was all about me being lazy that takes a
lot of confidence uh I feel like going
into most interviews people are stressed
out you know yeah so the fact that you
were able to make that joke and
initially land the job before the
interview even starts is pretty
impressive well I was stressed out
because you know
I
grew up watching Conan and so the first
time I'm meeting this guy that I watched
who's like a comedy God for people in my
generation any you know even younger
Generations it's it's when I'm trying to
get a job being his assistant so I had
to like be like Oh I'm a professional
but I'm like oh my God I watched you
growing up I love watching your show and
yeah it's it's very nerve-wracking and
then very quickly it it went away I just
very quickly got used to him and how
quick did you guys like hit it off when
you started working for him I would say
it was pretty instant I think that the
day after I got my job he he and I went
to coffee and then we just sort of
talked about what we both wanted out of
like what I wanted out of my job and
what he wanted out of an assistant and
then we both were just kind of gelling
and then a few months in he made fun of
me speaking Armenian he said it sounded
like I was arguing with Dracula when I
was talking to my grandma
and then uh after that the entire
Dynamic just went to [ __ ] it was just it
went from being oh we're both
professionals I have a notepad and I
will take notes and then it just went
into like oh your dick oh you sound like
you're arguing with Dracula what was
Conan's reaction to you writing a book
because essentially the book is about
him even though it's about you if that
makes sense you know what he was very
supportive I have to give him credit
where credits Do Not only was I came up
to him and I said I want to write a book
I want to call it the world's worst
assistant and my friend gave me the idea
she even gave me the title and I went to
him the next day I said are you cool
with this and he's like not only am I
cool with it I'll write the forward send
it to my agency if they he they can set
you up with an agent to shop it around
so he was super super supportive and
then as the book was coming out I was
like what am I doing I'm completely
capitalizing on the success someone else
achieved yeah and it made me very
uncomfortable and that I had a breakdown
and I talked to Conan I was like how are
you okay with this how are you okay with
me taking all these years that you spent
working hard and then me sort of like
sucking at the teat of your celebrity
for my own gain it made me feel really
uncomfortable and he was like you know
it's a book you wrote and you should be
proud of it and you know it's a fun book
and he he he he talked me off the ledge
but I was
I was like I don't even want to promote
this book I can't do it I just felt so
uncomfortable but I got over it as soon
as the check came in as soon as that
first check so that Advance came in oh
we're good baby
foreign